δηλαδή ι απάτες να κλέψει χρήματα από κάποιο να το πω ότι ο λογαριασμός του
πλόκαρε και στει λε αριθμούς να σου φυσικάόλον αυτό υπανδιμία το ενήσχισε από ή περισσσότερα
πάραολέα παραπλύ παραπολύ είναι ήταθεγια το ηλεκτροικό έγκλημα γεννικά αναδομαγκόδμο ήταν η μεγάλη μας ανάπτυξη
του διαδεικτύου των λημάτων αυτό ιατί όλοι πρειωρίστηκαν πίζω από την μοθότην του ηλεκτρονικό υπολογιστή
είναι εκεί που αναπτήθηκαν οι κανότητες μερικόν που δεν ασχολού να προηκουμένος με αυτό το
θέμα και έγωλα αυτά ήταν πλι ήταν πλήνι για τηγια το λεκτρονικό έγκλημα γεντικά και
είχαμεβλέπου θα βλέπουμε σμερα ότινα στην πάντη μία υπήρχαν πολλές υποθέσεις απόσπάσεις χρημα των απο
ι απάτες να υξαν ότι απόμή πιο πολυσύγορο θριγορο πρα πολέ πάρα πολύ πιον ήταν
το ποιο συχνόμεσα στην πάντημια ήταν αρκετά τα θέματα ήταν τότε ήταν πολύ τορόμα που
πληισίαζαν γυναίκες διαφορ αξωματούχι προσποιούντα αι αξωματούχι είτε του εμερικά ντικού στρατού είτε πλι άρχηετι
ανηλότι ότι δήποτε και πλησίαζαν τοεπ ένα πολλά χρημαστό χιε μέτα και πήρχαν πάρα πολλές
τότεγυναίκεσ έχουν χάσει θημαντικά απόσατριάνχλις μερικές φορές δεκαπτεχιαδες δεκαχιδιαδες προσπηγούνταν ότι διαδεικτιακά αρχισε ν κά
αγάποιον τρόπον μια σχέση μετάταζαγάμω και τα ζαγάα ακριβώς και όλ αυτά και πεδική πορνογραφία
ότε χροσθεύσει και πάρα πολύται αρεθμή μας και είχανε μεγάλον πρόβλημο στον τομέαν αυτό παιδική
πορνογραφία αφόύ το άνοιξης ένα θέμα το οποίο θεωρώ ότι από τα σοβαρότερα από έχει
τογραφεία σαςστην κύπρο κάθε χρόνο είναι περισότερες υποθέσεις και γιατί είναι οι ευκολία από μπορίς
να πλησες